you
you
to cloud on air there are live webinars
from Google cloud every Tuesday
my name is pushkar Sharma I'm a product
manager in Google Cloud IOT today we'll
be talking about cloud IOT and talking
about the business use cases and how it
applies to IOT all the way from edge to
the cloud you can ask questions any time
there are Googlers on standby and we'll
be taking those questions at the end of
the presentation but let's get started
so today we will be talking about first
we'll start off with measuring the
business outcomes with IOT then we'll
talk about the cloud IOT in general how
we see it then we'll talk about our new
offerings cloud IOT edge and edge TPU
and then we'll move on to talk about
security and cloud IOT provisioning so
let's talk about business outcomes with
IOT so there was a there was a survey
done by McKinsey and it turns out that
84 percent of the companies were stuck
in pilot phase for over a year and at 28
percent for over two years and about
thirty percent of these pilots only
could make it to the scale so about 70
percent of these pilots never made it to
the production right so so what's really
good what's really going on I mean we
call this as a pilot purgatory so
essentially what's going on is you
started with pilot and then they you
never have a success with it so what are
the key success metrics which we found
it comes down to really the business
alignment you know either
are you aligned with your senior
executives do they do you have support
is there a strong business case or
vision and how it will impact the
business or is there an internal
alignment and how to do we execute and a
long-term perspective on that so really
it comes down to an ROI if you can
establish our Y you can easily get these
alignments and that's where you can move
from pilot to the next stage so what we
focus on here is the
I and not the how because many times you
start up with the technology proving our
POC whether the technology works and and
it starts off with a very grassroots
thing but you want to really try to go
down to the making a business impact and
that's how you're going to move from
from a pilot to the full scale so when
we when we think about business outcomes
you know how you want to really start
think about so it all starts with
digitization and what is really
digitization is really a lot of things
which are analog today they are they're
a your physical blind-spot these are
things which are not connected or even
if they there is a data they are in
silos so what do you really want to do
is you want to connect these things
customers staff processes in a unified
manner in a unified system so now you
have all this data coming together in in
single platform and from here on now you
can start to analyze and calculating
these insights and these you know this
is your data big data analytics on on
your past data historical there you can
start to see what the things were going
on where was the process how things were
happening in yours in your business
environment but then you want to also
start to look at can you create a
prediction models can you use machine
learning and advanced artificial
intelligence to create predictive models
for for these four for your business
which really indicative of the key
performance indicators and then you want
to use all of this information which is
the real-time information coming from
the business the past behavior past data
and insights the predictive models of
what's going to happen in future to
really start to think about workflows
and that's very important because there
are workforce happening today but they
are not connected they are in isolation
you want to think about how can I take
that process which is in physical form
happening today
can we make it more digitized can we can
we make it all connected in a seamless
way and that's where you can start to
start optimizing and and get benefit
from the
from the from IOT so when when we look
at our t ry so it really comes down to
that you want to be measuring ROI return
on investment so there is a direct ry
which is essentially can with revenues
and and cost you want to increase your
revenues can you sell more or can you
reduce your cost are the things you can
do to reduce you said that's that's
direct and there are things you can do
using IOT because with with IOT you have
more data more insights so you can
enable features enable sales service an
able man you can do you know improve
pricing measured demand and elasticity
you can also you know look at the cost
and can we improve efficiencies uptime
reduce the risk and improve quality but
then there are other benefits of of IOT
which you can expand to for example
marketing and and this is where you want
to know your end-users better can you
use the data to to understand their
behavior if they are connected through
IOT you actually can and you can then
upsell and cross-sell products and you
can do personalization based on that
customer you can also you know build
better products because now you
understand the customers you understand
their behaviors and and in generally
have a better relationship with the
customer they connect with you more you
have a better brand on the engagement
science when it comes to service
delivery especially you want to have
that deep customer knowledge how they
use their product can we proactively
reach out to them can we help them can
we make their experience very delightful
and also with all the data which is
coming through you actually start to
understand a lot of opportunities which
were in your blind spot and and you
start to see how can you use that data
to my new businesses and create new
business outcomes which were not
possible before so let's go into few
examples of different verticals
hopefully this will resonate with you
and give you an idea of how you want to
start think about
different use cases in IOT so for
example manufactures if you think what
manufacturing was really important I
mean important thing in manufacturing is
is like the is productivity the
factories are operational 24 by 7 can we
keep the uptime can it be more efficient
can it be more safe because many of
these manufacturing heavy industries are
inherently have challenges there because
this is a live environment and very high
temperature and extreme environment
there so you could use predictive
maintenance to make sure we'll talk
about some of that later on but
essentially use artificial intelligence
and machine learning to create
predictive models for your machines so
now you have a better understanding of
when these machines is going to fail so
you can take action upfront you can also
understand what are the factors which
are driving the failures so you can work
on that and extend the life of your of
your machine so essentially you're not
only improving the asset utilization but
you're also reducing the downtime the
second aspect of manufacturing is the is
the process there it could be inventory
supply chain or different processes for
example in cars it goes through paint it
goes through retrofitting testing and
you want to understand how much time is
taking between each process you want to
optimize for that and if there is an
inventory which is access piling up you
want to reduce that see so these are all
different processes you can understand
by using IOT and and and getting a
real-time insight what's going on and
then you wanna not only in the factory
but also especially in just-in-time
manufacturing it goes beyond the factory
it's also connected to your vendors and
upstream and downstream supply chains
and you want to get a very good sense of
how supply chain is functioning is there
in going to be any shortages of of
components that may impact your
production and also delivery maybe
customer experience in terms of delivery
of these products and any in Journal you
wanna understand how your your employees
are doing how your machines are doing
and can you improve your productivity
and reduce your
failure rates and have a high ROI for
your customers
there are many partners explain a mile
relay or Tammy plus clear object these
are different partners which are working
they are actually using Google cloud
platform to deliver that and and clearly
if you have use cases around that you
can also reach out to us and we can help
that help on that tier likewise on oil
and gas is slightly different same
extreme use cases but here the business
outcomes are really around first of all
can I get better resource mapping can I
understand where next set of oil is
going to be can you use machine learning
and can I use satellite image image data
to get that understanding also I want to
optimize the machines and and their
failure is important and and and where
different assets are the trucks are the
real machines and even employees are
you're a surgeon and this is where you
want to understand are they safe as in a
safe environment if there is going to be
a problem you want to be up you you want
to predict that and if there is a
problem you want to evacuate and n the
safety is very important so these are
these are the key use cases in you know
one gas there there are partners like
Cisco los and again relay or foghorn
they they operating in different within
the whole IOT architecture they operate
in some are in more an edge someone in
cloud but but there are a lot of
partners Google has where which can help
in this these use cases so let's talk
about like logistics primarily when we
say smart transportation is really about
logistics and that's that could be
vertical by itself but is also feeds if
we talk about manufacturing and even in
retail it feeds the rest of the
industries as well and here the asset
tracking clearly like these trucks needs
to be tracked so as a tracking is
important but many times there is also
the product on those trucks which is
important and you want to understand for
example if it's the coals to already
understand how the temperature
conditions are even if you if you're
transporting something
needs to be maintained at certain
temperature then the telematics of these
vehicles how fast they're going are they
following their routes did they deviate
from their routes needs to be notified
in real time so you can take action on
that and and then also just like any
assets we talked about predictive
maintenance you want to understand the
the prediction of when these assets are
going to fail can can we do something to
enhance their life alive what are the
key failure modes for these assets so
let's talk about healthcare so we'll
talk about healthcare and and pharma and
med tech they're two slightly different
but very similar use cases so healthcare
this is about for example hospitals this
is where hospitals or extended daycares
where you're dealing with patients and
really what what the main goal for a lot
of these hospitals in and in healthcare
industry is really to serve patients and
the patient experience is the most
important thing their health is the most
important thing so you're using IOT to
first of all a measure the assets so
there are lots of assets like where the
wheelchairs are where the beds are where
the IV pump is so so when there is a
need for it customer the nurses don't
have to go look for it and they can
address the patient as fast as possible
also what happens is because there is so
much unpredictability around these
assets you end up buying more than you
need and it increases your cost and
these are expensive equipment you end up
having a lot more of inventory and and
that adds to your your cost overall and
then we know about this connected health
use cases around monitoring of key
vitals of the patients while they and
the facility like mental page mental
health patients or infants at such aware
you want to make sure either they don't
leave the facility and the key vitals
are there if they fall you want to be
able to detect follow detection and take
appropriate action as quickly as
possible
then let's go into retail there are lots
of use cases in retail we are already
familiar with many of them we can all
associate with it so one of the key ones
especially for the business comes down
to better engagement with the customer
because for retail the experience in the
store is the most important thing and
can you use the technologies like
beacons cameras and geolocation based on
notifications to create these
experiences and n location-based
notifications and marketing on site you
may want to also use image detection and
video analysis to look at footfall or
you can use our five DS for that and
understand what parts of the store are
our high traffic areas and can they be
used to improve your promotions at
product placement and in general the way
you operate your business automated
check outs are also very important
because it's part of the customer
experience and can you do more with IOT
with understanding who the customer is
what products they have what a counter
is associated with to really improve
that and now this is and then then
there's a lot of use cases not just
around customer experience but also the
back store operations and a lot of that
is about the best customer experience
but also involved into entry so do you
have the right amount of inventory at
hand is their lack of inventory can you
can you replenish quickly so when
customers come looking for something it
doesn't run out and then can you also
have a better understanding of how your
shelf and how the products are moving on
your shelf what are the fast mobile
products but a slow mover can you
optimize their placement on the on the
shop let's talk about Pharma and met
tech so this is really about deter this
is about pharmaceutical companies and
medical technology companies who are in
the business of helping customers from a
medication standpoint and their main
goal is to
ensure that customers are the patients
are taking medicines appropriately and
it's not only good for their customers
but also good for the business where
they can improve the adherence of the
medicines again that really that way
they can improve their revenues but also
having a better patient engagement not
only improves the brand but also allows
them to do automated interventions so if
a patient is not taking medicines they
can notify them or if it's connected
insulin meter where you could measure
the insulin levels and inject
appropriate amount of insulin to the to
the patient that can be done automated
we as well and then there's a big part
about Pharma in medical is that they
spend a lot of time in the FDA process
in the regulatory process and they have
to go through those clinical trials
which is very expensive and often time
they don't a lot of these clinical
trials fail because they just don't have
enough sample points but with IOT you
can actually improve and accelerate that
because now you can start to get a lot
of data live and that will improve the
way you go to market and you can launch
your products faster okay so let's talk
about Google Cloud IOT what do we mean
by that so when we look at Google our
cloud IOT platform they're really you
want to think from both devices all the
way to the clouds on the very extreme is
the devices and and these are the
devices which could be edged device for
example and we have a product we'll talk
about shortly is a cloud I already edge
which allows you to do three things one
is it allows you to connect to the
Google cloud this is a protocol edge IOT
core which does it securely and I make
sure the connection is strong and easy
for you to develop as a product and
second is the edge ml which is how can
you do inference on the device into
machine learning on the device and and
and create those outcomes without
relying on the cloud we do support
Android think this is
Google OS for IOT devices which is
hardened built specifically for IOT for
the best security but we also support
other operating systems like embedded
devices and then X OS as well and and
finally these are the CPUs or the
processor units also there is CPU with
the general-purpose or m/c used can be
GPUs for advanced machine learning
capabilities and then we have a
dedicated product we just recently
launched called edge TPU which is for
machine learning inferences on the chip
itself and it's in a hardware
accelerator and we'll talk about it
shortly too and on the right side is the
clarity core which is the entrance point
for all the IOT data into the cloud and
this is basically a gateway to the clock
inside the cloud for the rest of the
products it basically pumps all this
data into cloud pub/sub and which is
essentially a message queue and from
there on different products within cloud
I can actually take up this data for
example you can use cloud functions to
create your own applications you can
also use cloud dataflow to do ETL
operations and transform the stored data
and store it for example in bigquery or
BigTable and then use machine learning
to get these data from these databases
create machine learning models and then
do either inference on the cloud or you
can send this models back to the edge ml
to create these inferences at the edge
as well and then you obviously have the
visualization layer on top of that
that's the last thing you could use
cloud data lab data studio or maybe
build your own insights on top of the
cloud platform to create those
visualization charts and reporting etc
so that sort of hopefully gives you an
idea we also have a Google Maps platform
which is also Google product which
allows you to get a better location
updates and you can feed that
information back
to the Google cloud platform to create
for example asset tracking use cases on
top of that so let's talk about white
cloud why Google Cloud IOT and what's so
differentiated about it so first of all
Android thing we have a unified
end-to-end integration with the
seamlessly it connects with Android
things and other OS and connects to the
clouds and makes the development of the
hardware and IOT devices easy it's a
global IOT service it's a purely a
server less service where you don't have
to maintain different hubs you simply
spin up your devices you only care or
devices data coming through you don't
have to worry about scale and it has
intelligence built in so it applies
machine learning and AI in the cloud and
allows you to create IOT which is not
simply basic use cases of for example
temperature monitoring but also create
prediction models around temperature as
I mentioned it's serverless by design
and this is true just like bigquery and
many of these products so it basically
is a global network backbone and a
front-end which is essentially powering
the billion plus user applications from
Google and pretty much all Google
applications are built on Google cloud
platform and then using the same network
backbone and so this is this is what is
powering the cloud IOT and you take the
advantage of that Network for your
application and can build applications
with the same level of reliability and
scale so let's talk about cloud IOT edge
so if you step back there is the edge
computing which is long back when it
when there was no cloud was all was all
on Prem but with there has been a lot of
advantages to the cloud and people been
really migrating to the cloud but there
are some use cases where there is a
little bit of edge which is still there
and and that's important from as various
use cases for example it could be
security
it could be that the fact is that you
may want you don't want some data at
this bottom mostly part of policy and
you don't want some part of your data to
leave on premises to the cloud so you
can you do a processing on the on the
edge there there could be use cases like
robotics where the latency is very
important so you don't want the
round-trip delay times to the cloud so
you may want to take certain actions
quickly and hence you want to do edge
computing likewise for predictive
maintenance we talked about a use case
about machine learning inference you may
actually be doing cloud learning by the
ML learning in the cloud but you maybe
want to do the inference in the in the
device itself
likewise object recognition so there
here's a here if you want to be taking a
quick for example it's a manufacturing
line and you want to be testing for
defects and and in order for you to have
the maximum yield and the high
throughput you're going to be doing the
fast you know object recognition and
again it's an inference on trim on the
device itself and and that's something
you want to do quickly likewise their
use cases we all familiar with smart
vehicles warehousing where there are a
GPS and here also you want to be taking
actions quickly or maybe the van
connectivity is not that reliable and
hence you you want to do edge computing
so what is a cloud IOT edge so as we
talked about it extends the clouds data
processing down to the edge it runs on
Android things and other operating
systems it connects to the cloud using
cloud using the edge IOT core stores
processes filters drives intelligence
and then you can run inferences for the
tensorflow light models locally and it
allows you to do next-gen of machine
learning at the edge and this is how it
really works you would start with the
building and the training of the ML
model in the cloud you aggregate the
data coming for
on the devices you I could get the data
you use a machine learning model to
train it and then you send it back to
you essentially would do it you would
convert that machine learning model from
tensorflow to tensorflow light and then
you would compile it for the the given
target if it is the GPU or general
purpose CPU or if it is edge TP which
I'll talk next you won't want to compile
it for that platform and then you would
install it since you send it back to the
device and you will start to do
inference on the on the device itself so
we talked about HTTP or several times of
what it what really is it so it is a
very tiny high-performance inference
chipset which which is journal which is
not a general purpose CPU it is built
custom-built for machine learning it can
do fast iterations and in its the first
phase is to build for my video and
vision because these are very high CPU
intensive and it can run concurrently
about plus 30 plus frames per second
this allows you to create high
performance machine learning at the edge
with the low power consumption lower
footprint and with this not only and
also the because it works seamlessly
with with the cloud it's end-to-end
implementation not not isolated where
you have to put it all together yourself
so you basically use cloud IOT core and
cloud Google cloud for machine learning
and send these machine learning models
back to the the edge TPU and you can do
inferences and we are going to provide
you the tools and capabilities so it's
it's very easy to use and and deploy
we'll also be providing with the HTTP
development kit it will be coming in
shortly which essentially would have an
HTP you would have a you know associated
CPU as well would have a secure element
we'll talk about this shortly it always
integrated on a system is kasam a system
on chip module which you could use to to
create applications and and develop this
application before you go into the full
production and this Psalm would actually
sit on example a Raspberry Pi so that
way you could reuse the development
boards you already have in one when do
you have and just put in this new Psalm
and which is already secured it's it's
connects seamlessly to cloud it has
security with built in and that will
allow you to improve and increase your
go-to-market we will also have a USB
connected HTTP oh these are the i-y
boards which you can connect to your to
your jalapa for development environment
and then you're going to do machine
learning on these as well ok so let's
talk about cloud IOT core and end this
in security so so so the clarity code I
mention is is the entrance point for the
for all the IOT data well what what
really is it so it's basically they're
two parts to it one is the protocol
bridge that's the connectivity part and
that's essentially your connectivity
through MQTT and HTTP protocols it does
automatic load balances takes the data
from the devices and puts it into the
pub/sub the second aspect to it is is
this entire device shadow or digital
tuner round like what those devices are
how they are managed so essentially all
these devices are added into projects
and registries and for each devices
there is a device ID and and additional
attributes which are required for
connection so for example will be public
key or a certificate and then there will
be additional metadata and state
information about the device its health
and business attributes of these devices
but also the telemetry data which is
coming through the devices for example
temperature and humidity motion and all
these different sensors which are on the
devices would be
on that so one of the very important
things about what these devices and IOT
in general is security and read from the
google has a very strong opinion on
security and we've been pushing the
boundaries on that so we actually allow
for the basic idea is that there is we
use essentially a asymmetric keys so
private key is built into the into the
device and the public key of that is in
the cloud and the way it works is that
the device it's over TLS but the way it
works is through jar tokens so there the
device will create a jar token and sign
it using the private key and this
private key is then sent it over to the
cloud and that signature as the private
key is not send this the sign jar T is
actually sent and jawed is signature is
verified by the cloud and that's how the
connection is established we so there
are problems with that one is that you
have to make sure that private key is
safe and secure and what you would end
up doing is and that's what we recommend
is using secure elements from microchip
or NXP which has a private key built
into at the manufacturing time and then
you use this private key so you
obviously cannot use a private key
directly so you would have end up having
a public key equal and you get that from
the manufacturer and you would put that
public key on to the cloud and when the
device boots up it does the same thing
it it does job creation and signs it and
associates with the with the cloud now
this is a very cumbersome process where
you have to write a script and and have
these public key is sent into the the
device manager so what we have come up
with and try to solve for is with the
cloud IOT provision this is a new
service which basically allows you to
manage this entire process easily
so to recap really there - problem right
so one is this key manager you have to
secure this keys you have to transfer
these public keys from the SE vendor to
the OEM
and then there is the the device
management part of it is that okay now
you have to make sure that these public
keys and device IDs are pre registered
onto the cloud and the same device ID
and and and the target information which
project ID and registry ID needs to be
actually on the kind of on the form
where so that means that you have to pay
a lot of attention it becomes a complex
process so what we're trying to do here
is we're working with silicon vendors
selection renders and to get these
public keys from them which was stored
you simply use Real ID or UDID or
additional information for security sake
to get those and claim those devices you
will simply easily create your targets
which is simply your registries where
you want to put those devices in and
when the device wakes up it simply asks
for where it needs to go and and it goes
there so this is exactly what's
happening in this slide as you services
as I said it's the same exact slide as
the previous one but the part here is
that there is a cloud IOT provisioning
service which gets the public keys from
the silicon vendors and get and allows
you to claim them and allows you to
identify these devices and and provide
the related configuration and also
provide an information where these
devices need to go as a target onto the
device manager in the cloud and so when
the device wakes up it and all these
devices are very generically you don't
have no worry about this if I see
they're very generic devices they go it
go and is you know basically says okay
I'm XYZ where am I supposed to go
it gets the new config which tells it
where to go and these config could be as
elaborate as you want it could be new
firmware could be anything you want this
device to do and then it comes back as a
new device and connects to Google Cloud
and that's how it gets authenticated and
starts serving so let's use that let me
I'll do a quick demo of this service and
this is available for early access but
let me give you a quick snapshot so for
example when I log in as a customer
I'm gonna be looking at a blank screen
obviously because there are no elements
I have claimed so I'm gonna go in here
in this news case I'm using real IDs so
I'm gonna have a real idea real reason
sensually all all the security elements
are chips they're wound up on a tape and
it's is wound up under in a real and
it's a package it's essentially the
package ID so I'm going to just put a
package ID here and I'm gonna just claim
it so it's going to basically go through
these reels and and these reels now have
shown up and these reels have been
claimed but they have not been targeted
so now I'm gonna be targeting into a
registry so I have a registry open here
and you can see this this is all empty
right now so I'm going to be putting
these devices in this registry and there
is a registry - one is the registry and
as in this project ID and that's exactly
what I'm going to be doing here so I'm
going to target it to this particular
test target here and I'm gonna assign it
so essentially what is going to do is
move these devices from this place to
the to the to that registry so it's
basically what it's doing right now is
going through this in the loop
checking for for these devices and this
device is now actually moving into the
into the registry so when I'm gonna try
to refresh here I should be able to see
shortly the devices should show up but
if you want to this is available as as
early access and you can sign up for
this early access by clicking onto this
link here and you know and then we will
get back to you we wanted to understand
your use cases as well and then we'll
provide you an early access so hopefully
it would have come up by now
ok so now these devices have come up and
you can see all these devices which were
empty
before and then it's very easy for us to
move from these devices and here the
devices have been empty so now next time
you have a next batch of devices you
coming into the exact same process so
you don't have to worry about where the
device is when these all devices are
very generic when they come up they get
their configuration and then they
connect with that we're gonna we're
gonna end the session here this is going
to be our last slide and then stay tuned
for Q&A and we'll be right back in a few
minutes it may be less than a minute and
then we'll take up the questions which
you may have so you know feel free to
give us any questions any feedback and
then we'll be right back with you thank
you
you
okay welcome back so we looks like we
have three questions here so let's get I
get going with the questions so first
question is in terms of cloud ID
provisioning I don't have secure element
right now but plan to use it in future
products can I still use this service
yes
so we clearly we are trying to solve for
the secure element use cases but that
doesn't mean that's the only use cases
we want to solve for so we will be as we
go through this process we will be
solving for the non secure element use
cases because there are ways for you to
create public/private key pairs today
and we want to be able to solve for the
for the part where you are confident
about the private key but the public key
need still needs to be connected and and
put that into the cloud repository and
we want to make that process easy so yes
that's a that's a short answer so let's
see the next question is do I have to
use edge TPU to take advantage of
Google's edge processing okay so yeah no
I mean clearly you know HTTP gives you
that advantage for the use cases where
you need heavy processing but there are
a lot of edge use cases where maybe
general-purpose CPUs is perfectly fine
because even on the M and now and AI
there is huge range of computational
requirements so you know we wouldn't
support GPU we will support
general-purpose CPUs and you know
whatever your model is which you have
created and it can be used through our
products to send back those models from
clarity to IOT and from cloud IOT to
cloud IOT edge and then you can use
these models for inference in the edge
and then if if you're going to use TPU
then we will support that that's not the
so HCP is not the only thing we're
supporting here next question we have is
can we configure cloud IOT edge plus
Android things plus h TPU
on the currently available raspberry pi
yes so as I mentioned
it is a psalm which is essentially going
to have all these things in in one psalm
and yes you could use the Raspberry Pi
with with that Psalm but when that Psalm
is going to be available sometime in
upcoming months it will be available so
you want to sign up for that early
access so let us know we want to work
with you
and so make sure that you are the first
customers but yes you could use any
general purpose Raspberry Pi and that's
the whole idea of their song you just
goes on top of it and you can you know
you start off with your projects right
now with our DHT Pio and then when
that's available you can make that HTP
you capable okay well thanks for all
these questions and thanks for your time
stay tuned for the next session
it's see each at Google cloud networking
1 or 2 its routing and VPC pairing thank
you again for your time and you know
feel free to go to the cloud IOT core I
mentioned there was this let me see
go to cloud IOT core website you can
sign up for the cloud iid provisioning
early access and also you can sign up
for the HT PU and cloud IOT edge early
access as well on our website ok well
thanks again and have a good day bye
you